these are difficult times for Angel
Mackenzie she's only seven month old but
has already witnessed the worst of a
conflict she knows nothing about the
most recent loss is her home in the
Democratic Republic of Congo's it Torrey
region burned down by a tribal militia
group she's just arrived at this refugee
reception center in western Uganda with
her mother Deborah Imani
and five-year-old sister Francine we
went back to our home village of Julie
last December to bury my father it was
attacked last week we left my husband
behind and I'm not sure if he's coming
her neighbor Cosima Burundi also fled
from Shore with her children and a few
belongings she says many people there
wanted to leave but have no money to
hire boats to bring them across Lake
Albert so there is no security at all
the militias come armed with machetes
they kill people a loot hiding in the
forest doesn't help us we are not safe
there at least 60,000 people from it
Tory have fled to Uganda since 2017 just
over 1,000 this month alone many more
are internally displaced it's a conflict
over land and grazing rights that has
gone on for decades militias are live
with warring tribes attack villages at
will some of the refugees here say this
time attack has linked to the land
farming community are there aggressors
and the violence has been politicized an
average up to 50 Congolese are arriving
at this refugee reception center every
day most are coming from an area called
Google all are telling us attacks back
home are intensifying
the United Nations is investigating
human rights abuses and possibly
genocide in Ettore in Uganda officials
with the UN refugee agency UNHCR say
they're preparing for even more refugees
more of a spike than than than
previously last year say like October
from October till now there has been a
monthly increase so we are seeing an
increase in in the inflow of the
refugees on the unit back at the
reception center baby Angel and have
family received biscuits their only food
they'll get until they're moved to a
transit camp where they'll have a hot
meal the refugee settlement areas are
farther inland farther away from their
homes and from a conflict that has
refused to go away
Catherine saw a al-jazeera Homa western
Uganda